welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season five episode three a rick
convenient mort a title inspired by al
gore's 2006 climate change documentary
and inconvenient truth and this episode
makes us feel the simultaneous
heartbreak over a breakup and watching
the world burn out of our control but as
always the episode is full of hidden
jokes callbacks horny animation details
so let's cheer ourselves up by breaking
them all down morty and rick by merch
from johnny d's custom tees maybe a nod
to johnny depp who in season one's rixty
minutes was jerry c500a's best friend
you're my best friend jerry smith i love
doing cocaine with you whoa i love doing
cocaine with you too johnny dab and
maybe in this reality the guy sells
custom tees including their rick and
morty pounder's shirt and another
reading compliments only acid rain burns
them coming from diesel weasel a parody
of cheesy captain planet
anti-environment villains like hoggish
greedly sly sludge ooze love loving the
early 90s design here fingerless gloves
open vest random unnecessary pouches but
it's just very rocksteady bebop he rides
this floating motorcycle that looks like
it's made of a semi-truck engine a
lawnmower gas tanks but also nuclear
fuel cells enter planeteena a female
version of captain planet voiced here by
allison brie her logo is a recycle icon
in the shape of a heart her synthe music
is based on the captain planet theme
song and she points to the camera and
says the solution to earth's pollution
is you just like how captain planet
would end every episode saying the power
is yours the power is yours ah such
wholesome times i miss them it's stupid
but when planetary knocks diesel weasel
down i love his little realistic
reaction
so rick drinks his first of many foamy's
genuine draft tall boys a change from
the past two episodes where he didn't
seem to be drinking and then he litters
the can you crazy rick she's right there
yeah get that aluminum morty it's eight
percent of the earth we'll need every
atom rick is right aluminum is eight
percent of the earth's crust though
still no excuse to litter morty shows
the family in early 90s according to
plan and tina i like how the animators
included some green digital artifacts
that you would see with videotape to
digital conversion in the polluted water
there's a dead fish a flailing seagull
and then this dolphin covered in a
sludge whose flesh has been eaten away
which later comes full circle when morty
becomes a perfectly whole dolphin in
that animation planet tina says mother
nature has enlisted the help of four
young adults from each major ethnicity
and when things look bad and i mean
really bad they combine the powers of
their elemental rings to create smee
planet these are parodies of the
planeteers the captain planet including
kwame who controlled earth wheeler who
controlled fire like eddie does here
he's voiced by steve bashemi actually
linka who's from the ussr controlled
wind like the russian woman here who
controls air and then the planetary gui
who controlled water but here it seems
like the powers were swapped between the
asian and african tina tiers but instead
of earth qingho says dirt now notice
there's no fifth one like mati who
wielded the power of heart though
arguably morty fills that role now morty
clarifies the age difference he's a
sentient amalgam of natural elements so
i don't believe age applies to her this
isn't the first adult relationship morty
has had nor the first time he's had sex
even like he hooked up with the mermaids
in the ricklandtus mix-up and then an
adult woman in the toxic rick episode in
season three but beth is later proven
right when she says 17 is 26 in boy
years because morty was not mature
enough to handle what a relationship
with planet tina would really entail
actually most adults probably wouldn't
be able to handle that summer calls
planeteena a phase 4 superhero i think
it probably not a nod to marvel phase
four but i do like the idea of the rick
and morty universe having multiple
phases of a superhero hierarchy make me
think she could be part of the pantheon
of the vindicators who are returning
this season and could reunite allison
brie with community co-star gillian
jacobs who voiced supernova of the
vindicators and also played linka in the
funnier die don cheadle parody of
captain planet which also turns the hero
into a homicidal maniac and summer says
just shoot me in the [ __ ] head until
i die hey hey none of that summerfest
yes summer suicidal face plant here is
exactly what rick does at the end of
autoerotic assimilation the last time i
can remember a rick and morty episode
ending so bleak which might be why rick
now steps aside from morty's upcoming
heartbreak and instead embraces his
hedonistic nihilism in the bee plot
meanwhile jerry doesn't eat the egg
casserole that everyone else is eating
and instead has his soft boiled egg and
toast
hey my egg play later you can actually
see him sadly dumping the yolk on his
plate and i like how morty asks is it
weird that she hasn't texted me yet no
what have i hot jerry said yes the same
time beth said no says a lot about their
relationship and rick says the third
planet is being deep impacted by an
asteroid referencing the movie deep
impact that came out the same year as a
similarly premised armageddon deep
impact though had a comment armageddon
had the asteroid so good of rick to
reference deep impact instead because it
was the better movie it just made less
money and when rick takes summer on the
adventure he puts on her morty's acid
rain damaged shirt after morty threw it
at his face earlier and she says and if
you don't like it you can suck my bigger
tit calling back the season three
episode when she tried to resize her
uneven breasts and now she has 2010 new
year sunglasses i i love the bit of old
previous new year sunglasses so the
wildfire blaze is the mesa leon national
forest that's named after the director
of this episode juan mesa leon and as
morty flirts with valentina noticed the
jackets on the ground at first he just
brought this jacket that he wasn't gonna
wear so that he could just have
something to sling over his shoulder and
then the older teen of tears arrive they
make her wear this vote no on prop 6
shirt california prop 6 would have
repealed the gas tax that's being used
to improve transportation infrastructure
and as morty and summer head to morglutz
i appreciate how adult swim had to
digitally blur them demonstrating eating
ass which the animators clearly leaned
into more just because the digital blur
looks so funny and then after seeing her
puke in a baby carriage rick hooks up
with daphne who is voiced by jennifer
coolidge known from the legally blonde
movies and played stiffler's mom and is
so funny in all the christopher guest
movies morty's night with planetean is
scored to the original song flowers by
rick and morty composer ryan elder and
mark mullman and as they hook up we see
it in the form of this watercolor and
crayon animated sequence in order to
convey their beautiful naturalistic
romance but also in this kind of
childlike way to show that morty is
going into this with an immature
attitude i like how we wipe into this
with the transition of double a
batteries since they were just talking
about recycling these batteries and
notice how a planet in a cloud blows the
morty wind turbine which then changes
direction to blow her
a morty b hovers near a dandelion a
morty butterfly flaps past this
solar-powered house with a barrel for
collecting rain water then a morty
dolphin jumps and then planetina with
angel wings not necessary because she
can already fly orbits a morty moon but
in that moon cross dissolves into the
supernova sun of morglutz showing that
contrast between morty's dreams of
saving his dying planet compared to this
other society hedonistically embracing
its apocalypse the more glitzy until
summer solis is collapsing in five zip
zops if we time it right we can skeet
together as the sun explodes sounds
amazing yeah each planet apparently has
different words for units of time here
they use zip zop kind of like that
annoying improv warm-up zip zap zop and
summer uses the alias of michelle obama
because of course she would meanwhile at
ecocon planetina gets summoned there by
the tina tears with morty still on her
so they distract the crowd with limited
edition funko pops for 50 now the black
hole that's about to envelop slart of
art has the proper event horizon design
that christopher nolan commissioned
astrophysicists to conceiva of her
interstellar which by the way is another
story that balanced space exploration
with an ecological crisis on earth
though dan harmon has spoken at length
about how much he hates that movie
script but hey is your monthly credit
card balance keeping you up at night
tossing and turning like you got ants in
your bed well upstart can be the bed
exterminator to help you finally feel
the relief of being credit card debt
free upstart is the fast and easy way to
get a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online over half a million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans from one thousand to
fifty thousand dollars loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and other info provided in your
loan application you can get approved
the same day and can receive funds as
fast as one business day don't let your
credit guard dead give you the bed ants
no matter how many late night cookies
that you eat you don't deserve to have
those bed ants i don't know why i'm
obsessed with the bed ants just find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com new rockstars that's
upstarts.com new rockstars and don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you so go to upstart.com
new rockstars slaughter of art is
populated with these three-eyed pink
aliens that we've actually seen one of
in the background before like at flips
and chits in season two summer wears an
ice skate on her head and she inhales a
joint through her nose nice meanwhile
two dudes wear piss jumpsuits with pee
tubes going up to their mouths don't
know what that's about the old people
dancing rick and daphne do the kitten
play dance from house party and when
eddie threatens to burn morty morty
fights back burning the ropes off his
own wrists and biting off eddie's ring
finger just like gollum does to frodo in
return of the king actually if you think
about it morty does similarly make his
own tragic fall in pursuit of that which
he loves most the tina tiers plan to
sell planeteena to a royal from a middle
eastern country who eats baby seals
though later makes it very clear he is
not meant to be a stereotype i am an
individual character i represent no
group so morty enters disguises a pizza
guy with his hat reading murder pie and
he tosses eddie's charred skull at them
i know those cheekbones like they're my
own it's eddie ho attacks
yeah she says dirt multiple times for a
continuous stream of it so when morty
takes the russian's wind ring he says
yeah airs multiple gusts all at once to
inflate and pop her head likes but when
confronting the royal he uses just small
bursts of each only to destabilize the
guy so that the baby seals can finish
him off now after the scene we never see
the rings again suggesting that morty
most likely gave them to planetina so
that she can control herself so even
though he dumps her he does leave her in
a position to continue her eco-extremism
now back on slart of art the people
count down with their language numbers
[Applause]
yeah three is three maybe a nod to that
classic snl celebrity jeopardy all you
had to do was write down a number and
you wrote
three
daphne reveals to summer her secret
weapons not if i keep rick's mouth full
of these
oh my oh my god oh yeah that's right
girlfriend
nice classic cartoon bounce sound effect
there but i also love that rick could
spot those under daphne's jacket to be
initially attracted to her meanwhile
back at home they'd play this
hilariously stupid board game called
don't punch my lunch i
don't punch my lungs which looks like
you just feed a construction worker food
and then punch him in the belly until he
pukes oh no
mom i hate you it's like these classic
stupid kids games like don't break the
ice or don't wake daddy mr bucket i like
how one of the game squares just looks
like your characters to take a [ __ ]
which might relieve all the food inside
that guy now jerry who probably picked
this game because we know from last
episode he loves stupid kid games like
fuggle four letter words here he rolls
double sixes but notice as he counts
squares while everyone else is bickering
he skips a square just so he can land on
the punch square now when morty storms
out he slams the door just once
and we cut back to beth but then back to
the door calling back the earlier moment
when morty immaturely slammed it
multiple times which tells beth here
that morty's defiance is for real now
over this next montage plays
kishibashi's i am the antichrist to you
an amazing song that fits perfectly with
morty gradually realizing planeteen is
actually a villain it starts okay with
her powering wind turbines to power city
putting out a forest fire scaring off
elephant poachers but then she like
slashes tires she torches a
congressman's home which by the way they
watch at eli's electronics which i'm
thinking is a nod to fry's electronics
an electronics store that was in burbank
california not far from the rick and
morty production studio but then she
confronts the coal miners
you're killing the planet your people
didn't get the votes now i'm assuming he
could be referring to some green new
deal legislation which would be held up
in the u.s senate thanks to the
democrats razor thin majority at the
moment in which the swing vote is
senator joe manchin from west virginia
who is a huge supporter of coal and is
very much against a lot of environmental
regulation so planetina cuts their
elevator cable and then just burns the
whole place down reducing these miners
to ash even one was still kneeling there
meanwhile breaking this miner's heart
reflected in his eyes you could see more
burning bodies ironically by burning
this coal mine planet tina might be
releasing even more carbon emissions
summer destroys the asteroid that was
gonna hit fergus nine and the guy most
upset about it of course is the one who
was screwing his dad which we'd later
see their awkward day of work in the
post-credits scene but another little
detail here whenever rick is talking to
daphne his eyeline matches the eyeballs
at the top of her stalks the guy makes
eye contact and on the drive back rick
admits it was pretty rick of you to
avert an apocalypse in a tantrum of
cynicism just to destroy one dumb
relationship i would have done the same
for you actually rick did avert an
apocalypse just to destroy one of
summer's dumb relationships back in
season three's rick mansion the stone
when rick stole the post-apocalyptic mad
max reality's energy source while
getting summer out of that marriage by
the way that guy was voiced by another
community actor joel mchale so morty
breaks up with planeteena and as she
flies away the animators included morty
and rick's graves all the way back from
season one in the backyard just another
reminder that this morty does not belong
here and will always feel alienation i
mean poor morty jessica just dumped him
after becoming a time god and that
fulfilling love life that he had in the
bad of acid episode was reset when
stupid jerry just thought the reset
remote was a tv remote even now when
morty is doing the dumping the kid is
cosmically cursed against ever
experiencing true love and as he sobs in
his mother's arms the floral wreath that
planetena had gotten for him now will
sadly as some petals drop just like
tears but saddest of all when you
compare this to the earlier shot notice
how morty has turned this wreath away
from his bed so that he would not have
to look at himself that is everything i
caught this episode but i will be back
next week to look at episode 4. you can
support this channel by checking out our
merch options including our loki
inspired shirt loki out of time at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you